der geehrte damen und herren genau haben
sie sich gefragt wie eigentlich die
spitzenkandidaten zum thema islamismus
sicherheit afghanistan
antisemitismus stehen an je in ihren
wahlprogrammen
[Musik]
konzepten welche visionen
maßnahmen handlungen wie man mit solchen
themen umgeht ich habe vergeblich
gesucht und ich frage mich warum warum
haben wir eine politik und vor allem
spitzenkandidaten die nicht in der lage
sind so wichtige themen die bürger und
bürgerinnen in diesem land beschäftigt
anzusprechen warum haben sie nicht den
mut sich schmutzig zu machen und vor
allem visionen anzubieten wie wir mit
diesem mit solchen themen umgehen
konnten wenn wir sagen dass wir zehn
jahre vor eine französische oder vor
französische verhältnisse stehen was
antisemitismus und islamismus an geht
dann ist es jetzt die zeit den mut zu
haben themen nicht nur anzusprechen und
bitte keine sonntagsreden keine
lippenbekenntnisse sondern wirklich
visionen wie wie eine vielfältige
gesellschaft schaffen wo wir alle
zusammenleben und wie wir vor allem die
sicherheit der menschen in diesem land
stärken und islamismus und alle
radikalen ideologien auch verhindern und
bekam von realpolitik lieber ahmed heißt
dass man die wähler in wahlzeiten nicht
ängstigt das ist nicht meine vorstellung
fußball ist ja und ja freiwillig ich
habe ja noch nicht richtig begonnen zur
entschuldigung so sagen sprechen leiden
diese ströme zudem mangelt dem jahrzehnt
du wirst eine diskussion solche
diskussionen werden der politik
aufgezwungen durch die wirklichkeit oder
sie finden nicht statt jedenfalls nicht
in wahlkampfzeiten und um dann auf
afghanistan zurück so mein eindruck ist
der warum beiden die sich alles so mit
den taliban ins gespräch zu kommen und
möglichst übermorgen schon
hilfslieferungen dahin zu fliegen usw
sie haben nur ein einziges interesse
flüchtlinge abzuhalten also dafür zu
sorgen dass leute nicht über den iran
und dann über andere staaten nach europa
kommt doch was ansonsten afghanistan ist
ist ihm völlig wurscht aber verschwinden
ich bin ja es geht nur darum dass ich
beobachte ich beobachte das geschehen im
nahen osten und im morgenland seitdem
ich geboren bin und es ist schon seit
mehr als sieben jahren vorzusehen dass
amerika die weltpolizei nicht mehr
spielen will es ist klar dass da eine
vakuum entstand ob das in syrien in irak
in saudi arabien kampf gegen iran aber
auch in afghanistan und ich fragte
eingerichtet ab q2 und ich frage mich wo
ist unsere außenpolitik wo ist unsere
vision wollen wir mehr verantwortung
übernehmen wollen wir nur die amerikaner
hinterher ziehen und nicht sicher sein
wie wir damit umgehen
oder haben wir eine zentrale rolle zu
spielen und wir haben verdammt noch mal
eine zentrale rolle zu spielen wenn es
um menschenrechte geht und diese
außenpolitik die in deutschland seit
mehr als zehn jahren nicht vorhanden ist
ist ein thema für den wahlkampf
wir brauchen eine außenpolitik und bitte
europäisch und nicht nur auf deutschland
bezogen und das vermisse ich genau wie
alle anderen themen die leider nicht
angesprochen werden muss die seite ganz
kurz mit rein haben ja ich frage mich da
auch wieder den darum an den anfang
zurück zukommt was macht eigentlich
armin laschet was will der eigentlich
von der welt also man hat das gefühl
armin laschet fühlt sich auch wohl wenn
er irgendwie wladimir putin die hand
schütteln kann ist darauf zu lesen
und hier noch mal ein bisschen rum
fahren aber außenpolitische haltung bei
hat auch noch über ein ja ja nein aber
ich erkenne auch nichts ich meine hat er
mal neu marx rom besucht ich habe nichts
erkannt wie die deutsch französische
achse wenn die dennoch existiert künftig
funktionieren will was an kanzler armin
laschet will auch von olaf scholz weiß
ich nicht er hat mich einmal beeindruckt
also soweit haben einmal mehr beweist
nähe von frau berbalk weil sich schon wo
ich weiß auch wenn die außenministerin
wird wird sie das nicht umsetzen können
ihre politik also das wird interessant
zu sehen sein wie eine spd cdu die ja
eher russlandfreundlich agiert haben
dann mit vblock und ob ihre worte dann
noch was wert sind das glaube ich nicht
also die entscheidende frage aufgeworfen
aus ist im grunde ich primär eine
außenpolitische folge sondern das ist
eine frage der migrationspolitik und der
zuwanderungspolitik und was wir gesehen
haben und ich meine das hast du immer
verdienstvoller weise auch gegen viel
widerstand darauf hingewiesen man kann
einfach sich beliebig viele leute als
ganz fremden kulturen hierher bringen
mit der naiven vorstellung die kann man
sozusagen über nacht wie und hopfen und
zu perfekten europäern oder deutschen
machen so lud das sind so sieht aber
auch ganz gut
und ich mich sagte herrmann dann bin ich
das entschuldigung
außenpolitik darf nicht eine
verhinderung von migration seien ja nur
ein aspekt der leber ein bisschen
konkret und ich kann mit diesen ich sage
einfach dass du musst einfach ausland
aufpassen wie die migrationspolitik ist
wer kommt ins land können wir eine
bestimmte zahl von leuten aus diesen
oder jenen kulturkreisen können wie
überhaupt die integrieren können die
sich selber integriert und wenn ich
jetzt in deutschland mich umhöre und
wenn man den sagt okay wir nehmen jetzt
tausende oder was von von afghanen auf
ich habe solche forderungen geist dort
zum teil in gewissen kreisen auch und
dann sagt doch nur normale deutsche
seite vollends verrückt geworden
[Musik]